Trump administration is diverting
billions of dollars from military
projects to pay for 175 miles of the
president's border wall along the
us-mexico border there are 11 different
wall projects including new and
replacement barriers Ben Tracy is at the
White has been what do we know about
where the money is coming from
well the Pentagon is taking 3.6 billion
dollars from 127 different military
projects now half of those are here in
the US the other half are overseas the
Pentagon is not yet saying which
specific projects are going to be
defunded now the Trump administration
says these military projects are delayed
they're not actually cancelled but a
democratic democratic aide tells CBS
News that Democrats in Congress will not
make up for the funding for these
projects so they are essentially
canceled in a letter to lawmakers
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper said the
border wall money is necessary to
support American forces which are now
stationed along the southern border now
the Pentagon says it's going to be at
least a hundred days before any sort of
construction will take place on the
border but this does allow President
Trump to say that he is working on his
border wall as he runs for re-election
Tony all right Ben thank you very much